[Musica]
sapete Mio padre aveva un gran gusto nel
vestire non era un dandy non era un
damerino Però è stato inverno che fosse
Io l'ho sempre visto con la giacca e la
cravatta indosso Insomma ci teneva
parecchio Eppure nel corso del tempo ci
deve essere stato un cambiamento nel suo
look perché un giorno in garage ho
trovato una sua vecchia giacca di pelle
era lunga sino al ginocchio aveva la
cinta in vita e i bottoni madreperlati
quando gliel'ho mostrata si è illuminato
in viso e mi ha cominciato a raccontare
la storia di un grande viaggio che aveva
compiuto con dei suoi amici quando aveva
20-30 anni hanno attraversato l'Italia
in auto e poi un giorno lui ha dormito
sul ponte di una nave sotto un tetto di
stelle avvolto solo fra i lembi di
questa stessa giacca che adesso li stavo
mostrando il tempo passa quella giacca
adesso era praticamente distrutta ed era
veramente difficile capire che fosse
davvero la stessa giacca di cui stavamo
parlando
la vita cambia in fretta la vita cambia
in un istante lo ha detto la scrittrice
Joan divion e io mi sono ritrovato in
questa parola quando un giorno
all'improvviso Mio papà è mancato oggi
vi parlo di questo in questo dedex e non
vi parlerò del fatto che il dolore è
utile non mi voglio dire questa cosa vi
voglio invece condividere
Quel piccolo grande insegnamento che ho
capito sulla mia stessa pelle quando
dalla dolore è giunta una trasformazione
quando sono riuscito a rimettermi in
piedi quando ho capito che per quanto
fragile per quanto scassato io dovevo
aver bisogno del mio cuore dopo averne
cura Solo prendendone cura Solo
prendendomi cura delle mie stesse
cicatrici potevo ricominciare a guardare
al Futuro E allora prima che questo
fosse possibile ci sono stati dei mesi
degli anni duri
quel lavoro perfetto che sembrava mi
stesse aspettando a Milano è scomparso
all'improvviso senza lasciar traccia
quella vita perfetta qui pensavo di aver
diritto è scomparsa l'attimo prima di
diventare realtà cosa è rimasto sono
rimasto io col mio dolore con la mia
famiglia e abbiamo deciso forse senza
neanche dovercelo dire di prenderci cura
a lungo e l'altro e per far questo ci
siamo coccolati abbiamo abbracciato le
parole di mio papà che era perso e so
cosa stavo pensando fa parte del ciclo
naturale della vita però noi eravamo
impreparati eravamo ancora impreparati a
dirgli a Dio e allora io mi sono
personalmente tuffato nei libri ho
vissuto 100 mille vite Sono stato un
marinaio sono stato un professore
universitario sono stato Corto Maltese
fra le Galli di Venezia ho vissuto vite
diverse perché avevo paura di affrontare
il mio dolore perché la mia perdita era
come una foresta buia era il totem delle
perdite Io non riuscivo a entrarci
dentro
E allora A un certo punto mi sono reso
conto che ciascuno di noi ha come
un'impronta ma come un odore il nostro
organo olfattivo è capace di riconoscere
10000 autori alcuni sono divertenti
pensate all'odore della dell'erba appena
tagliata pensate all'odore della pioggia
sulla nuda terra altri ci fanno battere
il cuore gli odori delle persone che
abbiamo amato ci restano impressi li
riconosciamo immediatamente non c'è
bisogno delle parole eppure le parole
servono per raccontarsi per raccontarci
servono a me adesso davanti a voi per
parlare di quello che ho vissuto prima
che tutto questo fosse possibile con i
miei genitori con mia madre scusate con
i miei fratelli abbiamo raccolto le
parole di mio padre ci siamo raccontati
i suoi aneddoti delle sue bizze quelle
piccole cose che rendono una persona
speciale che spesso diventano speciali
solo dopo quando è impossibile
confrontarsi i suoi maglioni erano nei
cassetti i suoi vestiti erano appesi
straordinario le sue penne Nelle scatole
sul comò all'ingresso per tanto tempo
c'era il suo cellulare come se fosse
andato nell'altra stanza come se dovesse
tornare ad un momento all'altro era
un'illusione e lo sappiamo però abbiamo
bisogno anche di questo per andare
avanti e poi un giorno è successo
qualcosa è successo che ho ritrovato
questa giacca l'ho ritrovata e l'ho
portata da un sarto dopo un paio di mesi
Questa stessa giacca mi è stata
restituita e finalmente era la giacca di
cui parlava del mio papà era lucida i
bottoni erano perfetti la fodera era
stata cambiata era la giacca perfetta e
io pensavo che quella stessa sera
l'avrei indossata la giacca di mio papà
sarebbe stata mia però quella sera è
passata e la giacca è rimasta appesa e
poi la sera dopo e poi la sera dopo Sono
passati mesi sono passati gli anni e io
Per quanto possa sembrare stupido non mi
sono mai sentito in diritto di usare
quella giacca che restava
la giacca di mio padre un tabù per il
figlio ho vissuto per tanto tempo in una
grande comfort zone un po' Come fanno i
granchi Avete presente i granchi vivono
fra gli scogli vivono protetti fanno le
loro tane si accoppiano fanno tutta la
loro vita Sono felici fra gli scogli
però non vivranno mai l'ebbrezza di
andare controcorrente non conosceranno
mai nuovi fondali vivono la loro vita
protetti e così stavamo proteggendo la
nostra stessa vita vivendo zavorrati
impantanali perché ogni ricordo che noi
proteggevamo mi ricordo che io
proteggevo e collezionavo era come una
pietra una pietra che metteva in uno
zaino e uno zaino che indossavo sulle
spalle e più lo zaino della capiente più
sentivo che stavo proteggendo e ricordo
il mio papà Ma più lo zaino era pesante
più io ero impantanato come in un eterno
presente uno spazio in cui non c'era
possibilità di futuro perché io stavo
soltanto pensando al passato
Poi un giorno
è successo che mia sorella che è diversa
da me perché in certe cose è un po' un
po' più pratica un po' più sgamata
diciamo ho visto questa giacca avverto
il mio armadio e mi ha detto la posso
prendere ma nel frattempo già ce l'aveva
sottobraccio e così quella giacca che
era all'inizio di questo decks e poi è
stata persa e poi è stata riparata di
nuovo È uscito dal mio radar emotivo era
perduta di nuovo finché un giorno l'ho
vista ricomparire stavolta indosso mio
nipote stavolta indossato Una
quattordicenne che la portava con quella
intramontabile svagatezza che hanno gli
adolescenti con quella strafottenza come
se fosse stata sempre sua quella giacca
aveva le tasche piene di roba e avevo
una macchia di gesso sul sul fianco la
portava con leggerezza la portava come
se fosse stata sempre sua la indossava
senza nessuna zavorra emotiva senza
sensi di colpa e allora
Qual è il messaggio il messaggio è che
la giacca è una giacca diventa un dono
nel momento in cui passa dal nipote
passa dal nonno alla nipote attraverso
me che me ne sono preso cura di Allora i
vestiti sono vestiti Si logoreranno si
romperanno arriveranno le tarme
i maglioni saranno nei cassetti ma piano
piano passeranno di moda le foto
ingialliscono e perdono i colori le
parole si perdono nel vento e gli odori
si confondono A cosa serve aver paura di
cadere se poi capita a tutti per quanto
possiamo vivere in una comfort zone per
quanto possiamo essere protetti dalle
pensiamo di essere protetti dai rischi
della vita prima o poi cadremmo prima o
poi il dolore ci afferrerà E inevitabile
perché fa parte del ciclo delle cose ciò
che conta non è aver paura di cadere ciò
che conta è quello che succede dopo
quando ti rialzi quando dimostri a te
stesso che sei in grado di farlo quando
capisci di che pasta sei fatto c'è un
proverbio giapponese per me molto
importante che non mi sono ancora
tatuato solo per pudore che dice nana
Carobbi yaoki cadi sette volte rialzati
8 quando cadi ti fai male e sanguini e
in quel momento pensi che tutto sia
finito e non parla soltanto della
perdita di una persona amata parlo della
fine di una startup parlo della perdita
di un lavoro del cambio di una città
alla fine di un amore o la rottura di
un'amicizia ogni perdita ogni rottura ci
fa un dolore ci crea una cicatrice non è
questo ciò che conta Questo è
inevitabile quello che serve capire è
ciò che accade dopo quando ti rialzi
quando capisci che devi prendere cura
dei Cocci del tuo cuore e in qualche
modo
frangibile imperfetto scassato con i
pregi e con i difetti sono quelle cose
che raccontano chi siamo sono le
cicatrici sul cuore che ci dicono chi
siamo per davvero e sono volta che
possiamo mostrare alle persone che
amiamo perché raccontano cosa siamo e
cosa abbiamo vissuto e allora Conoscete
il paradosso della nave di Teseo gli
argonauti partirono durante
i tempi antichi per una grande impresa
sedussero ninfes sconfissero Monster
insomma la solita roba dei miti greci
Poi però tornarono in padre quella nave
per quanto Maestosa iniziò a marcire
ferma all'Ancora piano piano ogni
singolo pezzo andava sostituito perché
era una vergogna che la nave degli
Argonauti dovesse marcire finché a un
certo punto non era rimasto nessun pezzo
della nave originaria nessuno è anche
una singola sartia tutto era stato
sostituito ma allora la nave degli
Argonauti era la prima quella che era
stata che era stata costruita quella che
aveva compiuto l'opera o era quello che
adesso era Folgorante in porto nuova e
brillante questo paradosso riguarda
evidentemente durante la nostra identità
la nostra capacità di abbracciare il
cambiamento e come la mettiamo con la
paura di perdere Come la mettiamo con la
mia paura di dimenticare Come la
mettiamo col fatto che io ti emessi per
lungo tempo che avrei potuto dimenticare
mio padre che avrei potuto perdere una
singola parola un singolo elemento e
piano piano dar vita ad una valanga e a
un certo punto non l'avrei più ricordato
è stupido io me ne rendo conto lo so
però è inevitabile perché il dolore
Porta questo e allora mi sono reso conto
che facendo anche delle richieste delle
delle ricerche che biologicamente ogni
sette anni il nostro corpo si rinnova
completamente ogni sette anni
biologicamente siamo persone nuove ogni
cellula si rinnova e le nostre idee e la
nostra paura di perdere e la nostra è il
nostro timore di tradire chi siamo stati
anche questo è un bagaglio che ci
dobbiamo lasciare che ci dobbiamo
prendere cura
il filosofo Nietzsche dice dovremmo
considerare persa ogni giornata in cui
non abbiamo danzato Perciò se accettate
il mio consiglio Prendetevi cura delle
vostre cicatrici piangete tutte le
lacrime che vi servono ma a un certo
punto riprendete in mani cocci del
vostro cuore e fate di tutto per
rimetterli insieme e se possibile finché
dura la musica
ballate e sorridete alla vita che vi
aspetta
[Musica]